montréal l'épicentre de la crise de la
coved 19 au pays cinq mois après le
début de la pandémie
le syndicat qui représente les
infirmières dit que les départs se
multiplient
ce qu'on voit beaucoup cette année
puisqu'on dit c'est plus ce n'est 47
aiguë si vous me permettez l'expression
des gens qui réoriente carrément leur
carrière aussi heureuse de l'ess de neil
on compte 363 départ depuis le 15 mars
dont ceux et celles qui se sont inscrits
au site je contribue somme toute c'est
deux fois plus de départ qu'à pareille
date l'an dernier
le cius précise avoir embauché un plus
grand nombre d'infirmières la pénurie et
éviter le syndicat n'est toutefois pas
rassuré on en a eu un constat accablant
mais je vais l'émission d'exaspération
de la crise la croche du gouvernement
par arrêté ministériel
depuis mars les gestionnaires peuvent
annuler des vacances est imposée du
temps supplémentaire aux besoins c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons qui a poussé
cette infirmière a quitté son emploi à
temps partiel dans un siège chez celles
des ans mais j'ai commencé à recevoir
des courriers du siège comme quoi que
mes disponibilités avait changé pouvait
être changé à la dernière minute les
quarts de travail qui m'imposait de plus
et pour moi c'était juste impossible
d'autres restent mais on ressente les
effets qu il ya beaucoup de temps
supplémentaire obligatoire et on essaie
de se relayer toute l'équipe mais
clairement manque de professionnels de
la santé côté infirmiers manque énorme
le premier ministre françois legault dit
que tous les efforts ont été mis en
place pour accommoder les infirmières
mais il reconnaît que le réseau manque
de ressources ce qu'on voulait s'assurer
qu'ils aient une couverture de service
vous savez on est en train de former dix
mille nouveaux préposés
évidemment ça revenait enlever une
certaine lourdeur sur les épaules des
infirmières par courrier le bureau du
ministre de la santé christian dubé
rassurer le personnel on écrit que
formation équipements et horaires de
travail plus stable seront au rendez
vous pour une deuxième vague de lakovic
19 ici m caron radio canada montréal